[Music]  this is us finally explains Jack's death  it's my fault this is us fans have been  teased throughout the entire series  about how Jack Pearson meets his end on  Tuesday's episode of the hit NBC show  titled that'll be the day fans got their  biggest clue yet and it may all come  down to a crock pot from the Pearson's  neighbors with the switch but it works  Thank You George we appreciate you  thinking of us  [Music]  et was with the cast at Sunday's SAG  Awards where they teased the answers to  Jack's death would be coming very soon  within the next couple of weeks you'll  actually witness it I promise you there  will be some answers before the end of  the season so not much longer so that's  a huge clue and and we're close we're  really really close to that that um that  questions everyone's been asking like a  year and a half now like how does Jack  that what why does he die how does he  die  [Applause]  [Music]